[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos de Inteligencia
artificial y de cómo esta tecnología
está llamada a cambiar nuestro futuro
aunque ella está en nuestro presente
desde los teléfonos inteligentes a las
redes sociales que utilizamos a diario
La Unión Europea es uno de los grandes
actores globales que ya ha empezado a
legislar sobre ella qué regulaciones
están llevando a cabo antes de pasar al
debate hacemos un repaso que es la
Inteligencia artificial y Qué medidas
quiere aplicar la Unión Europea la
Inteligencia artificial es ya una
realidad está presente en muchas
situaciones de la vida cotidiana aunque
no seamos conscientes Incluso en
medicina hay máquinas de Inteligencia
artificial capaces de ver heridas
internas que un ser humano puede pasar
por alto
la Unión Europea ha empezado ya a
legislar en la materia primera Región
del mundo en hacerlo y ayudar también en
la inversión de esta tecnología sin
embargo depender de la Inteligencia
artificial también conlleva riesgos
Especialmente cuando se toman decisiones
sin supervisión humana
otra de las cuestiones que preocupan en
el uso de videos Deep fake en que
aparecen personas hablando de forma muy
realista y resulta muy difícil
distinguir si es real o si son creadas
por la Inteligencia artificial lo que
conlleva preocupación por su uso en
campañas de desinformación la
Inteligencia artificial tiene amplios
beneficios pero su regulación en los
países europeos se considera clave Para
no caer en sus peligros
y para hablar de Inteligencia artificial
y que se está haciendo desde la Unión
Europea tenemos a dos de las personas
que más saben sobre la materia en el
parlamento europeo la eurodiputada del
partido popular europeo Pilar del
Castillo bienvenida a Pilar un placer
estar del nuevo con este programa en
este programa de France 24 igualmente y
con Iván García del blanco del blanco
del grupo socialdemócrata bienvenido
Iván Hola Muchas gracias Un placer
gracias a los dos la Unión Europea está
empezando a legislar en el ámbito de la
Inteligencia artificial algo pionero en
el mundo Pero por qué es importante
regular la Inteligencia artificial Pilar
Bueno yo creo que lo que hay que
centrarse es que es importante regular
de la Inteligencia artificial porque de
la Inteligencia artificial Se podrían
regular muchas cosas y sobre todo en un
futuro se Irán regulando más aspectos
porque se vayan detectando temas asuntos
que afectan a los ciudadanos
a las empresas a la sociedad de su
conjunto y requiera A lo mejor
una regulación ahora mismo lo que se
está regulando son todos aquellos
aspectos que inciden en los derechos
fundamentales cuando se utilizan
programas de Inteligencia artificial
para temas Como por ejemplo el empleo
y otros que pueden incidir negativamente
dependiendo de cómo se utilicen sus
algoritmos y pueden generar
un impacto negativo en personas o en
empresas
se está hablando como comentaba
Pilar esta cuestión más ética sobre la
Inteligencia artificial fuiste ponente
del informe sobre ética Por qué qué
Cuáles son los problemas que podría
llevar la Inteligencia artificial en
esta cuestión bueno la Inteligencia
artificial es una tecnología y es una
tecnología muy poderosa es tan poderosa
que desde el punto de vista práctico
haciendo Ya un cambio prácticamente de
modelo social como no hemos vivido como
humanidades de la primera Revolución
Industrial Entonces tenemos que hacernos
a la idea de que los beneficios las
posibilidades que tiene esta tecnología
son enormes inmensos pero al mismo
tiempo por supuesto genera como
cualquier otro tipo de tecnología
riesgos lo que tenemos es que o tratamos
de anticiparnos a esos riesgos y
queremos hacer compatible este
desarrollo tecnológico con como decía
Pilar hace un instante el respeto a
nuestros derechos fundamentales y
también a los principios que nos
conforman como sociedades la Unión
Europea es un espacio de civilización y
como tal queremos proteger ese espacio
de civilización y al mismo tiempo
también hay una segunda vertiente que
para nosotros es muy importante que
tiene que ver con que el desarrollo por
el desarrollo significa que
tecnológicamente las cosas van avanzando
pero no necesariamente un beneficio
social queremos garantizar que haya
también una equidistribución de este
crecimiento que va a haber y que haya
también materias que a lo mejor no son
tan rentables a corto plazo
económicamente pero sí socialmente que
se sigan también investigando y
desarrollando En eso estamos en este
momento justamente sobre la inversión y
también sobre la investigación
piensa en Inteligencia artificial se
suele pensar un poco en películas de
ciencia ficción en robots pero la
Inteligencia artificial es una realidad
de Estados Unidos y China están
invirtiendo masivamente la Unión Europea
en el buen camino para despuntar la
Unión Europea está buscando
e intentando encontrar esa velocidad que
necesita para no quedarse rezagada
detrás de potencias como Estados Unidos
y China para eso hace falta desde luego
inversión hay que tener en cuenta por
ejemplo que el 80% de la industria que
genera los semiconductores los conocidos
más popularmente como chips que son
absolutamente imprescindibles para el
desarrollo de infraestructuras digitales
se producen en Estados Unidos y que
china es también un competidor
extraordinario en ese sentido la Unión
Europea por ejemplo
ha aprobado hace poco en el parlamento
se ha aprobado una sobre chips sobre
semiconductores que pretende crear un
fondo de inversión público privado
aproximadamente de 11.000 millones bueno
llegaría más allá con la participación
Privada de euros para desarrollar
la fábricas que produzcan esos chips
aquí pero también hay un programa nuevo
en esta legislatura que se llama digital
european que está dotado con más de
7.000 500 millones de euros para estas
infraestructuras digitales no son para
solo para chips sino también para
supercomputadores de novísima novísima
generación que también Son
imprescindibles para que tecnologías
como la Inteligencia artificial puedan
desarrollar todo su potencial para esto
se necesitan estas infraestructuras
digitales de las que estamos hablando
hemos hablado un poco de los riesgos
éticos también hay evidentemente hay es
una tecnología muy positiva también para
Para nuestras vidas Pero cómo se puede
encontrar el equilibrio entre los
beneficios y los problemas que genera
Bueno en eso estamos estamos intentando
encontrarlo efectivamente se trata de
crear un espacio de respeto y de control
hacia los derechos fundamentales al
mismo tiempo que no se entorpece la
investigación es difícil encontrar ese
equilibrio virtuoso entre ambas cosas
pero quizá hay que hacerle la reflexión
de que la Unión Europea nuestras
democracias al final Como modelos son
precisamente eso un equilibrio entre el
desarrollo económico entre la creación
de riqueza del emprendimiento Y por
supuesto la protección de los derechos
fundamentales y también de alguna forma
el respeto hacia la justicia social
también como un elemento fundamental
también de de estructuración de nuestro
modelo no en fin antes hablaba Pilar de
muchas cosas que son importantes por
complementarlo también
lo más importante es que Hemos llegado a
la reflexión de que esto lo tenemos que
hacer colectivamente es decir que qué
país a país por mucho que haya
estrategias nacionales está bien que las
haya país a país en un contexto
internacional en el que haya agentes tan
poderosos tan potentes como Estados
Unidos China la India jugando en el
ámbito de la inversión y la
investigación o nosotros lo hacemos
colectivamente o nos vamos a quedar
atrás como nos quedamos en el pasado con
La gran carrera de internet no y por
poner un ejemplo de esos 750 mil
millones de euros que conlleva el plan
next generation you aproximadamente el
30% algo menos del 30% está condicionado
al gasto digital para que nos hagamos
una idea de la dimensión de recursos que
se están movilizando de que ha habido
una reflexión previa por parte del
gobierno de todo de toda la Unión
Europea y por parte de las instituciones
europeas sobre que hay cosas que tenemos
que hacer conjuntamente
en los últimos meses se está
revolucionando un poco el mundo con esta
nueva herramienta el chat gpt un chat
con Inteligencia artificial capaz de
responder a cualquier cosa o aún tiene
algunos fallos están rompedoras se puede
regular que como por qué es positivo en
realidad estamos ante un desarrollo más
una paso más en esa escalera
de evolución de las tecnologías
digitales si pensamos en las que tenemos
ahora en la mano y utilizamos todos los
días
entramos en un buscador y a ese buscador
le podemos preguntar por escrito muchas
cosas que tienen que ver desde con la
salud a la alimentación a cualquier
aspecto que te contesta porque tiene una
serie de datos que los Trata a través de
Big Data y a través de Inteligencia
artificial ahora y te da unas respuestas
esto es un desarrollo adicional es un
desarrollo superior el chat gpt lo que
hace es que
bueno es una Inteligencia artificial que
está entrenada para poder responder
teniendo en cuenta el contexto también
teniendo en cuenta toda una serie de
variables de parámetros que dan mayor
calidad a las preguntas que se le hacen
a las respuestas a las preguntas que se
le hacen que está preparado para
mantener una conversación etcétera sin
duda es un paso más que va a tener Pues
un gran impacto y que Bueno estamos en
esa línea de desarrollo constante de
transformación digital estamos en pleno
desarrollo de la transformación digital
y en cierto sentido desdepende de qué
perspectiva lo veamos pero en los
albores de la transformación digital en
los comienzos y vemos como no solo año
años sino que se van la semana casi mes
a mes hay nuevos y nuevos elementos que
van configurando
toda ese nuevo ecosistema esa esfera que
es la digital no y ya para acabar Iván
como última como última pregunta se
habla mucho de este gran potencial de la
Inteligencia artificial pero también
puede provocar que muchas personas
puedan perder sus puestos de trabajo
está la población preparada ante la
revolución tecnológica y estas
implicaciones que puede llevar bueno es
una gran pregunta para empezar quiero
retomando también la cuestión del chat y
para que la gente sea consciente
nosotros en nuestra interacción estamos
entrenando gratis por cierto a esa
herramienta que aprende sobre la marcha
que cada vez se va auto mejorando es la
característica además que tiene la
Inteligencia artificial además basado en
una en un modelo neuronal que imita al
modelo neuronal cerebral para que nos
hagamos una idea que estamos hablando
efectivamente
hay cuestiones muy vitales que tenemos
que tener en cuenta también en cuanto al
modelo de futuro efectivamente va a
haber una gran transformación en cuanto
al mercado de trabajo a mí yo prefiero
hablar desde un punto de vista positivo
de transformación más que de eliminación
de puestos de trabajo porque es cierto
que ya a día de hoy hay vacantes casi un
millón de puestos de trabajo en Europa
en el tecnológico que no somos capaces
de cubrir luego nuestro sistema de
formación necesariamente va a tener que
también adaptarse a ese nuevo modelo Y
con todo lo antes lo haga mejor pero es
verdad que hay capas de la población que
no van a tener quizá Pues por su estado
vital la ocasión de poder reciclarse
tenemos que pensar en qué vamos a hacer
también con esas personas porque hay que
darles una solución nos quedamos con
esta reflexión Gracias Iván y Pilar
Lamentablemente nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo a ustedes les esperamos en el
próximo programa de Europa hoy Gracias
por ver France 24 en español
[Música]